it's been a few months um
where we didn't have the quantum the
simon's quantum colloquium mostly
because um
because it seemed like everybody was
suffering from covet fatigue and
zoom fatigue i guess and
and so now that everybody has had a
chance to be out and about and
and meet people for a little while
perhaps this is you know it's it's a
good time to get back to the the locum
so um
i'm i'm very happy to uh
to introduce boyz barak as our first
speaker of this uh you know the renewed
colloquium uh so boaz is um you know
i've known him for a very long time
i i guess from the time he was just
finishing up his phd but he's now on the
faculty at harvard uh boss has done done
you know uh he's he's done some
truly foundational work in
in cryptography um
you know these
non-black box arguments uh obfuscation
and in
computational complexity he's the author
of a book um the the book on
computational complexity with with
sanjeev arora and of late he's he's um
he started
thinking about quantum computing which
is which is a fantastic thing
and so
um
and today he'll tell us about about
spoofing strategies for noisy quantum
circuits i believe so boys
uh really looking forward to this
thank you thank you omission and it
really is a
pleasure to be here and um
if people have questions
it's hard for me to monitor the chat but
so if you must feel free to uh
interject and let me know if there is a
question i should
answer and and this is based on a joint
works with uh soon choi chinning
shingo martin kalinowski and misha
looking and kunal mahwah
so
so i'll
i'm trying uh i'll try to take a
somewhat unified look in this talk on a
quantum speed ups
and a
unified two views uh two lines of work
that
maybe be not often
unified in the same talk
so
generally when we are discussing quantum
speed ups with
say current devices we have some kind of
a device that someone has constructed a
physical quantum device
which
we can think as having some input and
some output and because
it's inherently stochastic so
the output
so if the input is stata or you can
think of that as the configuration for
the device or the input of device and
the output is a
somehow a string y that is uh
sampled from
some probability distribution q of theta
and then
and let's say this string y has a n bits
and roughly speaking we think of this
device as uh
requiring some something like n
resources
uh constant times and resources for us
to er execute it or to
run it or construct it
and we
when we talk about speed ups we want to
compare with a classical algorithm and
so our comparison
is some classical algorithm that has
many more resources
than uh the quantum device
and what we want is that uh basically
there should not exist any classical sea
of
comparable resources to the quantum
device that
gets close to the quantum device
so so far this is vague but
to make this more precise what we really
need to do is to come up with some
benchmark
right so so we need some benchmark
uh so this is some
function that takes maybe the
description of the input and
the output distribution
and assigns the scores
a score to that distribution
and
what it means for a quantum speed up it
basically
that means that
the quantum device
gets a value uh
on this benchmark that is higher than
the value that any possible uh
classical device can get so basically
the performance on the quantum device on
the benchmark should be at least epsilon
more than the performance of the best
classical algorithm within some resource
bounds say if we're looking at
exponential
speed up then we've been at most
two to some epsilon n
resources on the same benchmark
so so far this is very very abstract and
i think this
basically captures any
type of benchmark we could think of
and i'm not sure if there are questions
at this point yeah yeah boys i think
there was a clarifying question about
where the randomness is in the classical
circuits
so so they think of the classical
algorithm as also possibly randomized
so i think there's also additional
randomness in addition to theta as input
yes so you can think of theta as not
necessarily random
random
it can be some configuration or it could
be random and then
and and the classical circuit could also
have
yeah some additional randomness in it
so yeah i mean
okay that's good yeah
okay
so and
yeah so so and let's continue so uh
so ideally what we would want from this
benchmark
is we want two properties of it one
property is really in some sense crucial
er which is statistically statistical
efficiency
so this benchmark in principle it's a
function of a dist probability
distribution it assigns a score to a
probability distribution
and we would like to be able to
approximate the benchmark with only a
a polynomial number or generally a small
number of samples from this probability
distribution
um if it's a benchmark where uh say
suppose the
you know the quantum device we would
need to uh
sample from it an exponential number of
times in order to evaluate the benchmark
then that would
basically be
infeasible
and the second thing is we would like
a computational efficiency so we would
like this not to be only statistically
efficient but also computationally
efficient
and as we'll see sometimes we can do
without the secondary property
although obviously it's much better if
we do have it
and an even a better property which of
course many of us care about uh but that
way maybe at this point right now it's
the cherry on top is that uh
this benchmark is actually something
useful in its own right there is a
reason why you would ever want a device
that
given peta gets an output that maximizes
the benchmark on data
and in some sense this
third point is also related to the
second one typically uh
if you could not even evaluate the
benchmark computationally then maybe
that also means that
it's probably not very useful because
you don't even know when you got
something good so
if there is some reward
for uh
for producing this output with a large
benchmark then typically that means that
you could actually know if the output
has large bedrock or not
so and
so let's yeah we can ignore the
usefulness for this talk
although of course it's important
and and
and the uh one one you know the standard
example that uh
of a quantum speed up is shows algorithm
right so uh the factoring problem you
can think of theta as describing a
random
n digit integer that is a product of uh
p times q for two primes
and the output is a factorization so the
benchmark basically given a probability
distribution it just tests if the
probability distribution is a
factorization of theta
and
this is a great benchmark
it's uh
widely believed that the classical
algorithms will uh that so quantum
algorithms can achieve uh essentially a
value of 0.99 in this benchmark
very high probability will output a
factorization it's widely believed that
all classical algorithms can only
achieve you know negligible
probability on this benchmark
um you only need one sample from the
benchmark or you know constant number of
samples to evaluate it
and um you can check for a efficiently
given a factorization you can just
multiply and check
so
this is basically completely solves the
problem of
a benchmark and and
and i i just seen uh this on the on the
e-print server i haven't yet read it but
i think the uh
just from the abstract it looks like
there is this very recent result that
looks to me very interesting by
kalayataal
who um
basically get
uh show that you could do this kind of
benchmark from any non-local game
assuming some
homomorphic quantum
cryptosystem so you can
basically demonstrate the
advantages so so we have these amazing
benchmarks and maybe
if the benchmark problem is solved then
uh
maybe the talk should
there is no nothing to talk about
and the reason that we are
not yet done is because right now we
still don't have these uh
fully stable scalable photo and quantum
computers that can run shows algorithm
for example
right so we still uh we want to do the
this
when our quantum device is a noisy
quantum device so we want benchmarks
where the
that that we can actually execute on the
quantum device
that we currently have
and this is the focus of this talk
so there have been basically two general
approaches for a
speed ups on these noisy quantum devices
so one approach
is being called sometimes quantum
supremacy sometimes it's been called a
quantum advantage
in this talk i'm going to call it
quantum sampling advantage
so to
distinguish it from the other
type of advantage experiment i'll talk
about so quantum sampling advan
advantage generally the idea is that
tether describes
some ideal noiseless quantum circuit
and uh we implement it on concrete noisy
hardware
so the benchmark is some distance metric
between probability distribution between
the probability distribution that the
noisy hardware produces the output that
the noisy power outlet produces say
on the all zeros thing when
the gates are arranged according to
theta
and
the ideal probability distribution that
the noiseless quantum circuit would have
produced
so is that um
is that clear
so so do let me know if there are
questions so so this is a one type of
benchmark and um
and and generally this uh yeah so so
here the the
quantum devices the noise implementation
of the circuit and generally this
benchmark if you choose the right
distance measure right then it does have
statistical efficiency generally it will
not be computationally efficient so
generally it will be uh
to because the ideal probability
distribution to evaluate it we really
need to evaluate the ideal quantum
circuit
so to uh classically be able to do it we
need to and
um to spend exponential computation time
but at least it's statistically
efficient if we choose delta right
and the second approach is a quantum
optimization advantage where theta would
be a description of some combinatorial
problem and for example a constraint
satisfaction instance
and
the benchmark is just the value so the
output is a distribution over say
assignments to this problem theta
the bench
the
device is some
implementation on some hardware of a
local quantum algorithm and for example
it is a quantum
quantum approximate optimization
algorithm
and
and the hope is that
we find some
instance and some implementation where
the value that we get in the benchmark
is better than what we could get in
clark a classical algorithm
and this benchmark has disadvantages
that it's computationally efficient
because given an assignment you can
figure out
what's the value of this assignment
and it's in fact even useful and maybe
that depends on exactly what a
theta is but generally it's even useful
so and
obviously it's something that we're very
interested in
and and
so these are two types of uh
results in this talk i'm going to uh
show a non-trivial classical algorithm
uh to that
achieves some non-trivial values of this
benchmark for
the where delta is the
cross-entropy benchmark
and the second thing is a partial
limitation for local quantum algorithms
so
showing that there are some limitations
to what you could get even very very
local algorithms
for a certain constrained satisfaction
problem
so i should say sorry boys there's a
question in the in the chat um maybe
i'll let mikael ask the question
directly
sure
mikhail do you want to go ahead
okay i i guess the question says are
there
are there known results that give
statistical efficiency here
what about the no-go result by cliche at
all
so i don't know the result by clash but
i mean the the xcb
is um
you can evaluate the xcb
i think under natural assumptions you
don't you do need the you you do get
statistical efficiency
it is true that for and i'll get to it
in a few slides
or
maybe a few more but it is true that for
some natural choices of the metric delta
you will not have statistical efficiency
so uh
maybe the most natural like the first
delta that you'd think of uh like
statistical distance or things like that
they they would not they would require
an exponential number of samples yes l1
distance like the total variation
distance is an example of a metric where
you would not
you would need a
exponential number of samples which is
why we cannot use it we need to use
other benchmarks
yes we don't
um so suppose the factoring thing the
the
uh can be cast as a sampling advantage
in a in a in a
naive way right i mean the the point
here is that complete you need to
achieve completeness with the relatively
small n that's the point
[Music]
so you know i can write down source
algorithm right i can do error correct
like a fault tolerant version of short's
algorithm
then that would give me what what i want
with a sampling advantage
right yes but the point is that the
completeness will be the end you need
for completeness will be tremendous
i mean
basically the point is that we cannot
run it yet right we don't have the
details right okay so yeah right right
so completely let's say completeness yes
yes we complete this with respect to
what we can do right now so uh so if you
uh want to say
uh factor 2048 bit
prime right now and
we don't have them
right right
so yeah and i should say uh
these results like i should emphasize
what these results don't say so
they don't say that
you know these are kind of negative
results
but they're very partial negative
results on this advantage type of a
algorithm so they don't say that the
current quantum devices can be
approximated can be simulated
they don't er rule out
using a
xcb in all cases and they also don't
rule out qaoa for all csps or even a you
know qaoa for a
a even for max cut they uh they do show
and and i think they maybe it's better
to leave this to the end of the talk
discuss both in the end of the talk and
in in the panel you can interpret these
things
i think there is both a half a empty
point of view and a half full point
point of view so you can say these show
some challenges to how you would certify
speed ups with noisy devices so some
things you have to be very careful on on
how you choose your benchmark etc and
they can also
look at
basically these results give us
some things that we need to bypass tell
us exactly what kind of things we need
to bypass if we want to
actually bypass these limitations and
then we achieve both a
sampling advantage and optimization
advantage
so
this is definitely not a quantum skeptic
talk or anything like that
but i think they are
interesting and
subtleties here which i hope we
will get to discuss
so no no more questions i
will continue
i'll start with the
results on a local quantum algorithms
this is a joint work with a moah
so and
the
setting we have is a constraint
satisfaction problem we have a graph or
hyper graph let's say now right now
think of a graph
and where each label
edge is labeled with some constraint
that takes
i should have said an assignment
over some alphabet of the vertices of e
and maps it into a number between zero
and one
and
for any assignment uh the value that
the
the value that the instance that uh
achieves it takes is the
average value for over all the edges
okay and then example a max cut is a
binary alphabet the constraints are a
one if the assignment on an edge is
different for both vertices and zero
otherwise
so for example this is a graph and
say an assignment here is uh you have
these blue edges and
and you have these blue vertices there
they say get a zero and the red vertices
get the one and the edges that are
solid those are the ones that are cut by
the cut and the edges that are
dashed are the ones that are not cut by
the cut
okay so this is
and i think this is actually the maximum
cut of this particular graph although
don't
don't test me on that i would not be
super surprised if i got it one
and
okay
so a local algorithm say a k local
algorithm is one
where it has the following form so it's
a quantum algorithm on some q dates
and
we have some way
so basically we run the quantum
algorithm we start with some initial
product state
and
we get some distribution uh which assign
the q a
a value between say one to d for every
uh vertex and then we map it into our
alphabet of the constraint satisfaction
problem whatever it is
and it we say it's k local
if the output at any particular vertex
uh it just depends on the initial
assignment
of uh
of things that are in say some k
neighborhood of this in the graph so
it's say it's one local for example if
it was one local algorithm then the blue
the output in this
blue vertex that has this arrow on it
will only depend on the initial
assignment
for it and its two neighbors and
similarly the output for this other
vertex
will only depend uh on the initial
assignment for um
for it and its two neighbors and for
example here you would see that because
the distance in the graph of these two
vertices
is a more than two
so they're
they don't have a common neighbor then
their probability distribution of their
output will be
independent it doesn't depend on it it
does depend on the instance data it's
not independent uh but
it's independent of any additional say
randomness
and in one example of such an algorithm
is the qaoa say which you run it for uh
maximum cutoff generally for csps
and the reason we like local algorithms
is that uh
at least
heuristically you can also make this
precisely
if your algorithm is local then it is
also a noise tolerant
so generally
if your algorithm
each output only depends on a small
say
a small number of gates
then
you know if the probability of each
gate to have an error in it is delta
then
as long as delta is small enough
compared to the number of gates that
your output depends on the name
you know most of you
most of your output bits will be correct
and in csps
generally if most of your output bits
are correct then you also get a value
that is
mostly
that is close to the value you would
have gotten
even if you had no noise so generally if
you have a local algorithm then the
impact of noise is bounded
well if you add a very say deep
algorithm you know very deep quantum
circuit
then and
you know eventually errors will
accumulate so so these are very
attractive for us in terms of uh
in in terms of actually running them on
actual hardware that we we have
and
eddie and how showed
that
these local algorithms and there have
been other results on
also in constant depth circuits and that
basically we do not believe there is
good computational complexity reasons
to believe that you could not simulate
these algorithms
so you could not classically produce the
same probability distribution that they
produce
and under may be stronger assumptions
you could not even approximate it in the
statistical distance
but it doesn't necessarily say that you
could not
uh
so so even with locality one you could
not classically fully simulate this
algorithm
but it doesn't necessarily say that you
could not match its performance without
simulating it and this is basically a
question we don't know the answer to
so this is the following is open
and i think it's
one of the reasons
i think it's a little confusing uh so
what he is saying here that there's no
classical algorithm that can seem that
can
sample from the same distribution so
even in a noisy case or what's this
result so so i think it at this result i
think it's in the non-noisy case if i
remember correctly but i think
you you with stronger assumptions you
could believe that it's also true in the
noisy case i don't know if eddie wants
to chime in
but
the actual probability distribution so
so there is two things right so suppose
you're thinking of maximum cut right so
you could i and suppose the
you have a particular instance stata
and the
qoa
outputs some probability distribution
over cuts
with a
expected value 95 percent
okay
so there are two separate questions one
could you output the same probability
distribution
and the second
is could you output a different
probability distribution that also has a
similar expectation that also has
expectation 95 percent
[Music]
and the first you know obviously it's a
much more challenging class a task for
classical algorithm to do
and the first we have some evidence that
it might be hard
and uh the second we don't know
and and this is basically i think like a
very interesting question one of the
reasons i wanted to give this talk is
maybe to polarize this question
which is this question wherever uh and
and this is a i should also say this is
a question in an asymptotic setting
and uh
in real life
nothing is asymptotic and
you know in real life the number of
locality is not necessarily constant
and the
number of qubits is not approaching
infinity but i think it's a very nice
theoretical question
which we don't know the answer to and
the question is the following
could it be the case
that
for every constant a local algorithm
um
you have a
in every epsilon uh larger than zero you
have a poly and classical c where the
poly in the the exponent of this poly
might depend on the constant epsilon and
the constant locality
and you think of n as going to infinity
and so for every csv and let's say the
csp is bound to degree so local constant
locality makes sense
and so for every for every particular
instance of every
point so so for every particular
instance the classical algorithm gets a
value that is as good
uh
you know at most epsilon was than the
than the quantum value
so
so i find the fact that we don't know
the you know the answer to this question
or even very good uh you know
empirical uh you know every
very good
conjectural answers to it i find it very
you know fascinating and i think i think
this is a
you know question we want to know the
answer to
so because you know if
you know we we know um
you know we we know that basically if
you had like fault tolerant algorithms
that are not local
then definitely the answer to this is no
because we can encode the factoring as a
as a sat instance
and use the pcp theorem so there will be
even like that instance where the it's a
you know
one versus seven eighths
so so we know that the answer to this
if you were talking about a general
algorithm quantum algorithm is no but we
don't know what the answer is when
you're talking about local quantum
algorithm
and
and the question uh there is a question
now i see in the chat something about
special classes of uh
graph so
so generally we don't know
how to rule this out uh
we don't know that this this as far as
we know this might be true for all
possible graphs and for all possible
csps
uh in in some sense we will see that
this is true for uh
in in this uh talk for
high girth max cut in one locality which
is you know a restriction on top of
restriction on top of restriction so and
but but for for an initial result i
think i mean we this is just
starting to explore this
boas are you assuming a geometry for the
locality is this like on a grid or
yes i'm assuming any graph but let's say
constant degree graph
okay but so these light cones could be
like
uh like exponential and depth of the
quantum circuit
yes but right but now we're thinking of
it constant and and the n goes to
infinity so uh
yeah so so so generally i think the this
is uh yeah generally um
you you could ask uh
yeah like um
yeah you could you could ask this
question for particular graphs and for
particular i mean i think this is the
first question you want to answer if for
example the answer to this question is
yes
then you could ask uh
how does uh you know the complexity of
this classical city
depends on the uh
on this locality and they could still be
very meaningful speed ups if for example
it turns out that you know the classical
c
needs to end in time that is uh
exponential in the light cone or
something like that
uh-huh okay yeah because these like the
graph is expanding or you know has
interesting properties it changes
dramatically i feel yeah yeah i mean
yeah and again like and i think what you
know and i probably will talk about this
in the panel but i think a good point
which i'm sure eddie will make if i want
my
i'm not going to make it myself
is that in real life the number of qubit
is not going to infinity and so it's not
a
so
so the locality is not necessarily the
right way to think about the localities
maybe not necessarily as a constant that
is independent of the number of uh of
beats but i think this is a
for a first theory question i think it's
a
it's a good question to know the answer
to at least i want to know the answer to
it
so our result basically we should we
just looked at one local algorithm and
we looked at a all maximum cut instances
of a large girth and say largely would
be larger than a
three or five i think no
i think we need no
no five cycles
and and
and we showed that
the
value that you get
in these graphs
uh
that the quantum algorithm is less than
half plus 0.71 over square d now this
looks like an arbitrary number but the
nice thing is that it is really actually
bounded in this case you you're getting
worse than what the classical algorithm
will get
so
at least in the high degree high girth
case
um you can show
that um
there is a a polynomial time classical i
mean and
i cannot show it but el allowing montana
and circus did show that there is a
polynomial time classical algorithm that
gets
um that
gets this value
that that achieves this higher value and
the other reason why i like this result
is that it's a different type of
technique than what previous limitations
for local algorithms
in the following sense
that uh typically the way people have
shown like
that the max cut is hard to approximate
for some local algorithms
is uh you basically show that
maybe a local algorithm cannot
distinguish
between a random irregular graph and a
random irregular bipartite graph
where
in the bipartite graph
the
in the random the regular
bipartite graph
the uh
the value is one
and in a random the regular
graph the value is close to half but how
close it to easy to have it's actually
close it's actually this close like a
0.76
over scroll d close so you cannot use
this indistinguishability type of result
to show limitations for
to show this kind of result
because basically the the in in this
instance the this is the kind of
domination that we're interested in in
the sense that for this particular
instance there actually does exist
a graph in a cut with a value at least a
half plus 0.76 over square d but
the quantum algorithm doesn't find it
and and
the classical algorithm yes it's local
but it's not one local the classical
algorithm
i believe it's
it's local i don't think it's written in
the paper but basically
uh it's um
um it's uh some
approximate message passing algorithm
which i think can be truncated to be
local but like the locality will be
terrible like the
and it's it's definitely like the
classical algorithm is not like the
quantum algorithm
so i should say we we have some ongoing
work where we are looking at uh
with relaxing the low girlfriend the
high girth condition so i think that
would not be a
deal breaker
but
right now our results
uh the technique which i'll show you
that breaks when we look at the two
locality
and uh also uh
is right now very
you know when you look at most csps that
are more complicated than max cutting
particular ones that own hypergraphs and
not graphs
and and
yes and in kunal mike also wrote in the
chat exactly the right answer we don't
have any locality
thank you
yes and um
in the audience please feel free to also
correct me in the chat and
or i add the information at any point
okay
so because the proof is actually simple
i wanted to
show you
at least a very quick overview of this
proof
so so basically our focus is we're going
to show the following lemma so 0.71 is
basically square root 2 over 2
so
the level follows from the following
the proof follows for the following
lemma suppose you have a probability
distribution with mean zero
and uh over the graph such that uh the
every two variables that corresponds to
vertices of distance more than two are
independent
then um
if you
if you take a random edge in the graph
then
and this is the regular graph then the
expectation of the the correlation
between x x j would be at most square
root 2 over d
and the lemma just follows like if you
have the lemon then the
the result above just follows directly
just
you know you just change from zero one
to plus minus one and you just uh
divide by two so square root two becomes
zero point seventy one
okay so the this is just a
uh
just the the
islama
and now and
let's look at the proof
so
let's consider the normalized adjacency
matrix of the graph
and we want to bound uh the expectation
of x i x j where r is a random edge and
expectation also for the x's and we want
to bound this squared by two over d
so let's see how we get there
so we start by uh you know kashish varts
take
the expectation of x and take the
expectation of uh over the edge inside
and then
by some manipulations that i'm going to
skip
you can show that uh
you can uh
that you can write you can bound this by
basically taking a
x transpose a squared x so basically
this
instead of taking the correlation
between say x i x j
for a
a random
x x j squared for a run a
random
pair um it's you'll take basically and
you take a path of length two
and you take the correlation between two
uh random points of this path
and um
and let's call this quantity mu so we
got that the quantity we're trying to
bound squared is bounded by mu
now
we basically can you know a squared
it's a
psd matrix and then
you you get this um
and um
and its eigenvalues are you know some
some
there's lambda i's then you take a to
the four it's like lambda i to the to
the four so
this is lambda i squared this is lambda
i to the four so again you do some
kashish words you can and
you can bound uh this expectation of x
transpose x a x divided by b by a
expectation of
in x transpose a f to the four x
uh divided by v this is you can do it
pointwise for every x in particular it's
two with expectation over x
so uh this is basically you take the two
endpoints of a length four path
now what we do we look at is the
following now we want to use this
assumption that we have
so if you if you look at the length for
path
then the only way there would be a
correlation between the orange point and
the red point is if this three-point
path from the green point to the red
point
was uh of happened to be of length one
so this is a length three path
so
it can be either
you know it can it can be of evil and
free or everything is different or it
can you know one edge could kind of
repeat and then uh it will become a
distance the two end points will be of
distance one and if the two endpoints
are of distance one then we basically
get the same term mu that we got before
so uh so basically we get here the
probability that the length three path
uh the two endpoints are a different
distance one
times mu which is the correlation
between two distance uh
distance two points
and now the there are two
options for length repairs to collapse
to become the distance one one is that
you take two edges and then a back edge
and the other is that you take the first
edge then go back and then go somewhere
else because this is a graph of high
girth
and that those are the only ways you can
happen each one of them contributes to
us like a one over d so you basically
get that mu is at most square root of 2
over d times mu
and now we do this algebraic
manipulation and we just get the result
okay
so this was uh
short and simple but uh it is different
the the
a different proof approach than the ones
that people have used for limitations of
uh local quantum algorithms before
okay so now we can briefly if there was
too much algebraic manipulations then uh
[Music]
we we're done with that
and this was
basically my summary of that part of the
result
so now let me talk about the the other
part which is these non-trivial
classical algorithms for a
sampling advantage
so now uh
if we ask this question about a sampling
advantage
and then we need some kind of a
benchmark
and one maybe the first benchmark that
quantum scientist would look at is uh
what we want is that the quantum device
has good fidelity with the two uh
with the true
state right so the
the true noiseless quantum circuit would
produce a quantum state
fee
and the f we can define the fidelity of
the noisy quantum circuit circuit as a
you know the the fidelity with the ideal
quantum state
so that i think would be maybe the most
natural definition from the point of
view of a
quantum scientist
but
this definition doesn't make sense for a
classical algorithm right
it's not a benchmark in a sense that
there isn't a
it's a
function of a quantum state and a
classical algorithm doesn't produce a
quantum state
so uh this is just uh basically um
you know the you cannot punish the
classical algorithm for not uh producing
a quantum state that would be uh some
that has to be like
against the geneva convention or
something like that
so when
so so this is not
a good benchmark but basically the same
benchmark we can define a version of it
which is the bhattichara
distance which would be
uh would correspond to would be the
generalization of these two probability
distribution of the restriction of these
two probability distributions
and you can have other versions like
total variation kill divergence the
problem is these all these natural
probability distance measures
generally they require exponential and
sample complexity in almost all of these
cases
you can have this probability this
distribution that is a very very far
from the uniform distribution
but uh it would take you many samples to
distinguish between that and the uniform
distribution
so we need some kind of a more exotic uh
distance measures and the one that
people have settled on uh
maybe there are others that might be
better
is this linear across entropy benchmark
and and
so this is the um
one way to sing yeah it's just a for
probability distribution why
you just get the uh
two to the n times the probability uh
so you you sample from y and you look at
the probability the probability of the
output that you would have gotten
and you subtract one
so in particular if say y is the
completely uniform distribution the
so if y is a completely uniform
distribution the the course entropy
would be zero
if y is kind of a random so if data is a
random circuit then the ideal
uh the ideal probability distribution
will get a cross and a
a linear across entropy benchmark of one
because generally
um
this will be a porter thomas
distribution and and you can show that
this would be the
uh
the expected of a you get expected
gaussian
the expected gaussian squared is one and
now you get the expected expected
gaussian to the four
is three three minus one uh
and
yeah i think it comes out to be one
maybe it's two but i am but a constant
and then
if c is
a is uncorrelated with data then
basically uh
a typical y will give two to the minus n
and then we will get a
cos entropy benchmark of zero so
generally in this cross entropy
benchmark if it's bounded away from zero
we think of it as non-trivially
correlated
with
the ideal distribution and if it is
negligible or goes to zero then we think
of it as uncorrelated
so it's a measure of correlation and the
nice thing about it is that
you only need to show that it's bounded
away from zero uh
you know if it's epsilon then you need
the poly and samples
so that's
even if you need the you know
exponential in in time so it is
statistically efficient it is not
computational efficient but
you know
at least it's something
so the way uh we do here is a cartoon of
how we do
sampling advantage experiments when we
are in a situation like that
then basically we have whatever the
benchmark value that the noiseless
circuit would have gotten
and then we we have this experiment
and typically what happens in this
experiment we can run it and at some
point uh
and at some point we have to extrapolate
because at some point we cannot compute
the benchmark but
hopefully the curve looks
clean and nice enough that we can
extrapolate and get a good sense
of what the benchmark would be if we had
been able to compute it
and then you know for it to be an
advantage it should be
a higher benchmark than what we know how
to achieve classically
and ideally i mean it should also be uh
for you to be a proper benchmark it
should be
under some conjectures better than uh
every
what the best classical algorithm within
certain resource bounds
so
uh you know with actual experiments you
you do this kind of thing and then you
you run the experiments on in the range
b
above of what you can actually
classically
verify but
you have evidence from the lower size
experiments why you think the benchmark
will be what it is and and google has
done it and
and also use ustc and then
and and they generally have gotten you
know for say 53 cubits 56 cubic 60
cubits i've gotten
values of the benchmark that is maybe
not very high
but at least i bounded away from zero
and but
at least for the google a case the
pundits and i have managed to simulate
and get an even better value for the
benchmark
with
with a classical computer
and
so and
i'm not sure there is some comment on
the chat which i'm not sure if i
understand so and i'm not sure if it's a
question or in
but people can feel free to clarify
so and
what we have done is used a single gpu
in in one second
and gotten worse results so we have so
while pan and zhang have
benchmarks that are larger than say
google and
google we have
given benchmarks that are lower than
google or ustc
but are
in the ballpark they are also
non-trivial and they're
much less
computationally expensive
and maybe also interesting is that at
least in some
there are many many different ways in
which you could extend
their algo
the architecture to 70
cubits or larger number of qubits
and
yeah so uh there is a comment that it
does not sampling the right distribution
yes i mean it is uh
we are talking here about the benchmark
and the benchmark is the xcb benchmark
it is not close to the probability
distribution with uh
yes so uh within some
other notions of
distance
and yeah we can um
but this is a very
a very good point which will uh i'm sure
we'll also talk about in the panel so
right now we are fixing a particular
benchmark
and in
in in
pz
and us definitely not us and fd not pc
are not
simulating in fact i'll
soon say exactly where we are not
simulating the
quantum circuit
and
yeah you you but you need to yes and
then there was a good question if you
you need to find the high probability
bit swing or you could define the
benchmark is to find
many of them but we can discuss this
more in the panel
so
so basically
one of the things that's interesting is
that
at least in some measures you might
think that usually the way you think
about in quantum supremacy and
maybe i'll put the graph on so usually
the way you think about in this type of
supremacy
experiments so in general when you have
a one
more advanced technology against one
less advanced technology
is that you just
turn the dial up and it's game over like
you know once a computer's a bit and
once computers uh
you know beat humans at chess uh you you
needed to wait maybe one more year you
just bigger computers and it's kind of
completely all over
so uh you might think that i mean this
still could be the case also in quantum
that basically we are now at the edge of
supremacy and the classical algorithms
could give a good fight but uh you you
simply scale it up
and it's all over
and
what uh the this results show is that
scaling up doesn't just mean increasing
the qubits that is not enough you need
to also improve the fidelity or decrease
the noise
so
so if you simply increase the
number of qubits
it might depend on exactly geometry of
how you do it but generally you simply
increase the number of qubits
you could actually be inheriting the
noisy quantum circuit more than you
heard the classical algorithm at least
for our algorithm so
so our estimation which is
estimation that we didn't run unlike
this
is that basically at 70 qubits for
natural extension of
the sycamore architecture architectural
70 qubits algorithm and google a will
and
will meet
and
so um yes and i'm not sure uh if there
is a question in the chat but maybe i
mean we can also like keep these things
uh
to the panel if there is more general
you should go on because
you're running out you know
yes let's let's say save so so the
intuition behind these things and let me
maybe i'll go a little bit is that
indeed in some sense it's exactly what
sergey said
indeed if you're just trying to maximize
the cost entropy benchmark
then
that then um
you can cheat
a lot
and maybe pandenzang is cheating one way
and we cheat in another way but
generally uh
yeah you can er
the
fidelity measure
or
say other standard measures of
probability distribution
can be a
if if if you're in an adversarial
setting and when you're the classical
algorithm you can
specifically be in that adversarial
setting then you can actually
manage to have a very poor simulation so
very poor in terms of say fidelity
simulation
of your
of the underlying circuit but one that
is actually pretty good in terms of xcb
and and we show that basically for
example uh
if you look at the noisy circuit
uh the ratio between xcbn fidelity or
algorithm in some sense
specifically tries to drive
this ratio
to very large values so it so it will
have very poor fidelity but very good
and
xb or at least pretty decent xv
so and
[Music]
and and one one one intuition for this
would be the following and again i'll do
it quickly because i think i'm running
out of time so so one intuition maybe
i'll just skip the calculation
um so so sorry it was um yes maybe maybe
since this is a critical part of it you
could take a few extra minutes okay i
didn't actually follow the last slide at
all so
it seems like it's an important slide so
first of all what's the blue and the red
dot what does it mean
okay so so here we we we measure uh two
we divide so we take our algorithm and
we take a noisy circuit
say
this also depends on the gate but let's
say this is all quantum now you you
don't have a cluster
nothing classical inside no it's not
classical because our algorithm
basically essentially
designs a quantum circuit that is the
different quantum circuit a different
noisy quantum circuit and then just
simulates it fully
so so this is just
quantum and and this
basically we look at the ratio between
the xcb measure and the fidelity
so
so you can see that if you have say a
low noise a
low noise noisy quantum algorithm you
actually
the the ratio is bounded so basically
xcb is very good proxy for the fidelity
if it's a little bit more noisy it's a
little bit worse but still decent
but
what we show is that you can actually
break apart the connection between the
two so you can
cheat in the sense of getting a good xcb
value
while uh
even if your fidelity is very poor
okay so so we we're deliberately
breaking and in some intuition why they
are different is in this slide
so the xcb is why the
this is the measure of x b between two
probability distribution now let's think
of fidelity is basically corresponds
you have to probability distribution
you can think it's the dot product of
the corresponding unit vectors right so
given a probability distribution there
is a unit vector which is the
square root of probabilities
so the fidelity or batachara
constant if you're thinking of it as
classical probability distribution is
just a dot product of these two
unit vectors
so now uh right now maybe this seems
kind of the same like uh
the
it's not maybe not clear
what's the difference
but here is a maybe an example that
demonstrated so suppose you have like
system with two parts
and you have two independent uh
probability distribution of these two
parts
so now suppose that the
xcb of one part is a chi 1 and this xcb
of another part is chi 2
then the xcb of the joint system
you can do the calculation right to get
the probability of y equals x you uh you
add one to the xcb and you divide by two
to the n over two if it's a system of n
over two bits
so you just do the calculation and you
you see that the dominant term of
assuming these two things are pretty
close to zero the dominant term is chi
one plus chi two
so the the xcb of two independent system
is the sum of the xcbs
on the other hand
uh if you look at the fidelity it's
basically like the dot product of the
two tenzod things which is the product
of the fidelity so the xcb adds while
the fidelity multiplies
so so you can see this is quite
different behavior in particular if say
you
you injected some noise into the circuit
that broke it into two parts
and you manage to get
a decent uh xcb
in
non-trivial accident in each part then
this adds up
well on the other hand if you were to do
a to do this with fidelity you kind of
lose because you take the product of
fidelities
so that's basically the intuition why
um if you have a noisy circuit
uh and there is the same amount of
noise but
it's distributed differently
this could have a dramatically different
effect on the xcb value versus the
fidelity now if the noise if you have
very few errors and they're in random
location then generally this will not be
the case they will have similar effect
on xcb and fidelity
but
if you
put these noise
in the right locations then then this
can make a very different effect so
basically
this is both due to activity and also to
some cancellations which
and
behave differently in exhibition
fidelity so basically
what our algorithm does is we take a
noisy quantum circuit but we
choose the location and the type of the
earth
so that way
they are
on one hand they chosen to make our life
easiest when we're trying to simulate
the circuit so they're trying to break
it apart to smaller systems that we can
simulate
and they're trying to maximize the
xcb so have like the smallest impact on
the um
on on the
on xcb so try and uh to make sure that
the the impact on xcp is small but the
impact on computation cost is large
and then you also do some post
processing to uh amplify this xcb
and uh yes and this is basically the
same graph you can see you know in one
dimensional circuit
or two dimensional circuit the algorithm
does you know very very quickly very
well uh in the sycamore thing we are
worse than google again uh
in this benchmark but uh
you can see that in some sense the
scaling is actually better
and uh in particular you can show that
for several architectures you can get
xcb that only
descends exponentially with the depth
rather than the size
of a
and that is a contrary
for this particular architecture the
avonson and gunner kind of a generic
conjecture
that
no classical algorithm could get a
it will need to
er
it will get only xcd that is exponential
in this uh
exponential in the size inverse
exponential in the size we can get
inverse exponential in the depth
and and
let me yes since i
am out of
time and
then let me
finish with some conclusions and then we
can i'm sure there's going to be a lot
of discussion so you can have the
you can look at the glass of empty and
the glass half full of these type of
results so in general for every
this is the lesson we learned from
cryptography that whenever you have
attacks or spoofs
they only get better they never get
worse right so classical algorithms
will only get better if you achieve a
certain value in the benchmark with this
classical algorithm
um
next year someone probably will find a
better classical algorithm
so in that sense that's maybe a negative
result for
the quantum optimus point of view but
but the other part is that quantum
hardware
gets better and also maybe techniques
for error corrections
and
as time gets by we get closer and closer
to uh the full
fault tolerance and once we do that then
there are like these qualitatively
different benchmarks that um
where the classical algorithms don't
seem to even stand a chance
and and another
you know negative result is that
while our results right now are just for
large girl for maximum cut i think there
is some indication that maybe some of
these ideas could extend beyond it
but uh
i should say that some current hardware
platforms like lookings do have some
non-local
operations for say independent sets so
some hamiltonian is not purely local
and this approach might extend beyond
the high girlfriend or max but it
completely fails if you once you get to
the point where the light cone
is uh is all the graph where basically
every output depends on all of the graph
and and
right now that's already the case in say
the sycamore circuit but the problem is
that the sycamore the if you think of it
for a optimization for uh csps
then and
this is not great because it has uh
every output is like 98 noisy and maybe
two percent not noisy and we would like
it to be the other way around but
eventually with lower and
in also the instances maybe are kind of
small but but in principle this uh
once you get
noise to be low enough so that you can
afford to have the light can be
everything then
all of our negative results completely
fail the the approach that we use
and also it doesn't rule out polynomial
speed up and we have a recent paper uh
with
an implementation where we seem to
observe that some some empirical
evidence for uh
some empirical evidence for a
super linear speed up
and and
and we've with something maybe the the
the negative result the negative view is
that you you cannot just simply increase
the number of qubits
but uh
every year people improve not
necessarily not just the number of
qubits but also the noise and the noise
really makes a huge difference so
we've seen it in some of this graph like
if you take a
if you reduce the noise even if you
don't reduce it all the way to fault
tolerance you could already reduce it so
that the
classical competition has a much much
harder harder
much harder uh yes and and also
and this may be like related to sergey's
question
these are not full simulation this
doesn't simulate the probability
distribution it just achieves the
cross entropy benchmark
and you could potentially find some
other benchmark i would just say that
it's good to have a benchmark that is
you know specified
written down and uh and one that we can
evaluate with using a polynomial number
of samples so uh
so so
if the our alternative benchmark that
would be and
very interesting especially if we could
find a efficiently computable uh
benchmark for these type of random
circuit experiments that would be i
think wonderful
and then
but we don't know anything like that
right now
and with that let me yeah uh finish and
answer questions
of the panel and let's
decide on how we proceed okay so thanks
thanks a lot guys that's um that's great
so maybe in view of the time we can move
on to the panel and then fold the
questions into that um perhaps um
perhaps as the panel you know uh panel
is being set up um you know uh
uh if there are any